[music playing]
NARRATOR: Although mainstream
science widely dismisses
the concept of reincarnation,
leading academic institutions,
such as the University of
Virginia, Duke University,
and the University
of British Columbia,
have entire departments
devoted to its study.
And according to their research,
a mounting body of evidence
suggests that the
ability of some
to vividly recall past lives may
in fact be a real occurrence.
GIORGIO A. TSOUKALOS: You
have thousands of reports.
So one has to wonder whether
there is something behind that.
There are studies that have
been made on these things,
and I wonder how long
it'll be until mainstream
science agrees with
the idea that something
happens to us after death.
The basic idea
of reincarnation
is that upon your death,
your soul departs your body.
You go to your
version of heaven.
And then you come
down into a new body.
An easy way to understand this
is that you can upload files
from your computer to the
cloud and then download
files to a new computer.
NARRATOR: But while scientists
are just beginning to entertain
the notion that reincarnation
may be a real occurrence,
the idea of a soul
leaving one human body
and entering another can be
traced back thousands of years,
to the very beginning of
Egyptian civilization.
Turin, Italy-- on display
at the Egyptian Museum
is the Turin King
List, or Royal Canon,
which dates back to
the 13th century BC.
The papyrus includes
a list detailing
the ancient Egyptian
rulers, extending back
to the very start of
Egyptian civilization.
We see all the timelines,
and all the kings were there.
But the first two groups
of names on that list
were gods, the gods of
Egypt, who they believed
ruled before the kings.
NARRATOR: Although scholars
fully accept the chronology
from the rule of
King Menes onward,
they discount the
time before his reign,
around 3,000 BC, a
time when these alleged
gods ruled over Egypt.
One of the first names
to be found on the list
is the god Osiris.
WILLIAM BRAMLEY: Osiris was
depicted as a human-like god.
He had human features.
But one of the most
curious things about Osiris
is that he was shown
with green skin.
WILLIAM HENRY: Osiris is thought
to have come from the star
system Orion
originally and was part
of a group of extraterrestrials
that came to Earth.
What's interesting about
the ancient Egyptian gods
is they could also die.
They weren't
necessarily immortal.
And when the god Osiris
died, centuries ago
according to Egyptian
mythology, he was
reborn as his own son Horus.
And Horus became a physical
incarnation on Earth.
And it is believed by
the ancient Egyptians
that all the pharaohs
became gods incarnate.
And once one particular
pharaoh died,
the spirit would then go
into the next pharaoh,
and so on, and so on.
So that this cycle of
reincarnation continued.